conseil du jour que faut-il emmené
lorsque l'on court et bien
imaginons aujourd'hui il fait beau pas
trop chaud je décide d'y aller qu'est-ce
que j'emmène première des choses quand
vous êtes comme moi avec une densité
capillaire de très importantes
nous sommes de plus en plus eh bien il
faut emmener une casquette ça c'est la
première des choses ça peut vous éviter
un coup de chaud ensuite bien évidemment
des lunettes de soleil c'est pas la
peine d'y mettre un prix fou des
lunettes de soleil tout simple mais ça
peut ensuite vous évitez les douleurs
ophtalmique un portable toujours un
portable pour signaler un problème de
santé ou alors signalé quelque chose et
puis d'ailleurs à ce propos n'oubliez
pas quand vous partez courir signalé
toujours à quelqu'un combien de temps
vous partez et là où vous allez et puis
ensuite ça ça se trouve dans tous les
grands magasins de sport ça coûte pas
très cher
de quoi boire ça s'attache autour de la
taille vous pourrez vous hydrater dès
que vous sortez plus d'une demi heure en
tout cas il faut boire emmené à boire
avec soi ça peut vous éviter là aussi
bien des problèmes j'espère avoir
répondu à vos questions à bientôt pour
de nouveaux conseillers running